The Taking of a bath
bathing sometimes it is taken the
bath in order to cool the body down due
to climatic conditions and other times
it is taken to remove sexual
impurity is this a permitted act during
the fast alhamdulillah
[Music]
as far
as bathing is concerned that is g
whether it's done for
uh religious F if you in the state of
Junu that sexual defilement or whether
it is done to clean your body to remove
the dirt or you're feeling sticky or
whether bathing is done because you're
feeling thirsty or you're feeling hot
whatever reason is done for as long as
the person does not swallow
water the fast does not get invalidated
so bathing is permissible while fasting
and there are several
a to show that it's
permitted it's mentioned in s bukari ver
number number three in the book of
fasting Hadith
number26 that AA may Allah be pleased
with her she says that the prophet he
got up from his
sleep in a sexually defiled state in the
state of
junub while he was fasting and he took a
bath and he continued his fast that
means bathing was obligatory here
because he had intercourse with the wife
so it was compulsory and he bathed
further if you read Sun Abu da volume
number two in the book of fasting Hadith
number
2359 Abu Bakr May pleased with him he
says that he heard a man saying that
when the prophet had gone to Al arj and
while he was fasting he poured water
over his
head because he was thirsty or he was
feeling excessively hot so even when you
feel thirsty or you feel hot you're
allowed to pour water over your head or
have a bath in the state of fasting
further it's mentioned in s
alkari Vol number three in the book of
fasting chapter number
25 Omar may Allah be pleased with him he
soaked His Garment in water and he W
it in the same chapter say bukari one
number three in the book of fasting
chapter number 25 it it's mentioned that
an please with him he says he had a tub
of water in which he used to sit while
he used to fast so all these Hadi show
us that taking Gul pouring water over
your head whether it be for religious
purpose whether it's F whether it's
optional muah whether you're feeling
excessively hot whether you're feeling
dirty whether you're feeling thirsty in
the state of fasting all the permissible
as long as you do not swallow water
while having a bath